Kuala Lumpur is the largest and most influential
city of Malaysia.
A population of Malays, Chinese, Indians,
and others form around the world, makes the
city a melting pot of coexisting cultures
that each preserves their own customs, traditions,
and cuisines.
The mixture of ethnicities, ancient architecture
and modern skyscrapers, and most importantly,
the mouthwatering food, makes Kuala Lumpur
a fantastic city to visit.
Now, let's start with these 11 things to do
in Kuala Lumpur.
Nothing dominates the skyline and screams
Kuala Lumpur more than the monster twin towers,
which come in at number one.
So, I am at the base of the Petronas Towers.
These are by far the most iconic landmarks
in the city.
At the ground level is a big shopping center,
and then, you can actually go to the, I think
it's the forty first floor or something like
that, and there's a sky bridge where you can
get a great view of the city from there.
There’s a beautiful park right next to the
Petronas Towers that has some of the best
drinking fountains I’ve ever seen in my
life.
Number two is the historical district of old
central Kuala Lumpur.
The area makes a great place for a walking
tour.
Despite all the modern sky scrapers in Kuala
Lumpur, there's still a historic area.
I'm just near the old railroad station, and
I'm doing a little walk around to see some
of the most historical, and some of the most
prized buildings in Kuala Lumpur.
So now I'm here at the entrance of Kuala Lumpur's
National Mosque.
Merdeka Square which is the Independence Monument,
and it's home to a ninety five meter flag
pole which is among the tallest in the entire
world.
Number three is the Menara KL Tower.
At four hundred twenty one meters in height,
the insanely tall communications tower touches
the heavens.
Dine at a sky restaurant or just admire the
unbelievable panoramic view from the top.
One the top of the KL Meanara Tower, at some
absurd height up here, pretty scared out of
my mind to sit on this ledge, but luckily
I am strapped in so I don't fall off.
Number four is Little India, known better
as Brickfields.
KL has a lot of Indian areas of town, but
the area of Brickfields is known as the largest
little Indian in Kuala Lumpur.
Brickfields is home to Hindu temples, small
food markets, stores selling saris and other
Indian clothing, and a tempting collection
of mostly south indian restaurants.
I personally go there for the food.
Number five, located on Petaling street and
popular with both locals and tourists, is
Kuala Lumpurs Chinatown.
I am in Chinatown on Petaling street, and
you can see lots of different stall of clothes,
mostly clothes, shoes, watches, dvd's, handbags,
all kinds of stuff like that, there are also
lots of restaurants both on this street and
on the streets surrounding the area of Chinatown.
Number six is the Thean Hou Chinese temple.
Built by the Hainanese community in KL, the
Daoist temple is dedicated to the Tian Hou
goddess or the heavenly mother.
I am at the Thean Hou Chinese Temple, it was
built on the side of the hill, so you have
the Chinese temple but they you also have
a view of Kuala Lumpur on the other side.
Center Market, also known as Pasar Seni is
number seven.
At one point, it was the original central
market of the city.
Today I think it's a little bit touristy inside,
but it is a good place if you're looking to
purchase souvenirs, Malaysian souvenirs, or
a good place to browse around for a little
while.
So, the central market.
Number eight is the KL Lake Gardens and the
KL Bird Park which includes the world's largest
in flight aviary - for bird lovers, it shouldn't
be missed.
The KL Lake gardens right now, walking around,
very nice scenery and also if you are interested,
there is the KL Bird Park, KL mouse deer park,
the butterfly park, and a hibiscus garden,
orchid garden, you name it, it's all right
in this area of KL Lake Gardens.
Number nine is the Batu Caves.
So I made it to the Batu Caves.
It's located just thirteen kilometers from
the center of KL, and is one of the most sacred
Hindu religious sites outside of India.
The two hundred and seventy two steps to the
top is an easy climb that's rewarded with
a gorgeous cave filled with Hindu religious
shrines.
At the bottom of the cave you'll find a series
of vegetarian restaurants where you can replenish
your calories after the climb.
Number ten is the central Chow Kit Wet Market.
Chow kit market, and it's one of the largest
fresh wet markets in the city.
And they have some of my absolute favorite
ingredients in the entire world, right down
here in these aisles.
Stink bean.
All the fresh ingredients you could ever need
to prepare a Malay feast are available at
Chow Kit.
There's also always a delicious array of fresh
tropical fruit as well.
Did you really think I’d end this list of
things to do in Kuala Lumpur without adding
food as an attraction?
For myself and most local Malaysians as well,
it's all about the food - and when you visit
Kuala Lumpur your mouth is going to rejoice
with the diverse selection of Malay, Chinese,
and Indian food available.
Malaysia is one of the best countries in the
world for food, and Kuala Lumpur offers something
tasty at every corner.
From Nasi Lemak to ikan bakar, char kuay teow
to bak kut teh, and banana leaf to tandoori
chicken, Kuala Lumpur is a food paradise.
So no matter what you're interested in, weather
it be history, shopping, or food, Kuala Lumpur
is bound to have something that will make
you excited.
Hey everyone, it's Mark Wiens here, I just
wanted to say thank you very much for watching
this video.
Please remember to give it a quick thumbs
up, also I've got a bunch of travel and street
food videos coming up that you're not going
to want to miss, so you see that big orange
subscribe button down there, go ahead and
click that button so you don't miss my upcoming
videos.
Thanks a lot and see you soon!